before we start creating our content
provider it's time to go back to our
weather contract we're going to use the
weather contract for both database
definitions and content provider
definitions these are the URIs that our
contract will expose to our data and
view some of them return a list or
directory of items and some of them
return a single item the first part of
the URI is the content Authority which
is how the system disambiguates your
eyes from different applications similar
to the relationship between a domain
name and its website a convenient string
to use for the content authority is the
package name of the app let's return to
our weather contract we'll add the
content authority and a base content URI
for our content provider to the
beginning of our weather contract next
we'll add strings the base path of our
you our eyes each URI essentially points
to a different table for each of our
tables location entry and weather entry
we create a Content URI that represents
the base location for each table now
we'll add some magical value to the
location and weather entry contracts
these contain special mime type prefixes
that indicate that the URI either
returns a directory list of items or a
single item now we're going to add some
URI builders and decoder functions in
weather entry it's convenient to have
these as it makes fewer places in your
code aware of the actual URI encoding
keeping this knowledge in the contract
if you're just going to have a URI with
a standard integer primary key which is
a typical way of distinguishing between
a query for an item or the query for a
list of items one can use the content
URIs with appended ID function strings
such as a location setting can be
appended with the append path function
we can also use these functions to add
potentially useful query parameters in
this case we use a query parameter for
the start date query parameters are
useful for when we have a fixed database
query that we want to have some limited
parameterization for in this case it
will be a parameter for our join between
the two tables
finally we have this function that
builds a two-part URI that contains both
location and date segments below this we
have helper functions that help decode
the URI structure this hides the URI
structure from our code as well and
places all the knowledge in one place
within the contract